طيب بس كان شفنا تانجو شفنا ثمان شو اقرب
الاعمال المسرحيه والدراميه لا باس
بالنسبه الي بحاول اعطي دائما من قلبي ومن
عقلي ومن روحي يعني بشتغل عليه بشكل كثير
كبير اذا كان الشخصيه تتطلب اني اعمل عنها
بحث فبعمل هذا البحث خصوصا لما بيكون في
شخصيات فيها يعني بتكون كومبليكيتيد يعني
همم بشكل او باخر همم
ما فيني اقول لك انه همم تفضل شيء عن شيء
وانما في بعض الشخصيات بتاخذ عمل وجهها
اكثر يعني مثلا زي هذه السنه منعطف اكبر
كان فيها جهد ولكن كانت اسهل من من شخصيات
ثانيه عملتها يعني مثلا منعطف خطر اللي
عملته قبل هذا المسلسل ونعرض على شاهد كان
من اصعب الشخصيات اللي عملتها في مسلسل
اسمه الرحله عملته بمصر
كثير بحبه هذا المسلسل وكمان شخصيه لعبه
شخصيه يشتغل فيها على
محقق هو ساخر محقق ساخر بتعامل مع الحياه
بسخريه تامه فكان فكره ال- ال- العمل
بالنسبه لي مع المخرج رامي حالنا انه مطلع
نوعا شخصيه همم الكاتب عموما من الاطار
همم خلينا نقول لك همم